e dove dobbiamo essere ragazzi se non
qua pronti per prendere mazzate sul buon
the binding of isaac se per quello ai
ragazzi neural stavolta voglio provare a
fare con hazard perché è da un sacco di
tempo che non utilizzo hardware
siccome è veramente difficile fare il
nuovo dlc di isaac voglio vedere seconda
dal per caso mi trovo meglio gli hanno
messo delle corna e dei capelli
partiamo subito con l'a13 per non
vediamo se c'è qualcosa di buono alzata
mamma mia che quel partenza da da
madonna a ragazzi a zell per chi non lo
conoscesse vali niente parte con una
carta che the fool che ti riporta alla
alla stanza iniziale non ha le lacrime a
questo oggetto di vomito di sangue è
l'unico problema è che parte anche il
volo quindi strafigo l'unico problema è
che parte con tre cuori neri e basta che
fa molto schifo questo sporco demoni vi
siete assolutamente una moneta laga
perché devo comprare il cuore grigio che
sta nello storage posso fare lo
ricordate
entro quad entro non c'era niente a meno
che non gli dà un record adesso
abbastanza utile una chiave ore dai
meglio di niente e poi uso defunto è
uscito niente niente moneta fa peccato
ma magari meno dal boss vediamo è molto
utile a dover perché permette di fare un
bello start cioè nel senso perché parti
che sei fortissimo ali fosse veramente
forte
ecco questo non serve a niente perché ti
permetti fa avere il volo più il dash
atac però non serve una sega di nulla
perché io c'ho già al volo e il dash
l'uso veramente poco solo per pulire i
pavimenti che va avanti o se riesco a
usare the vision right now
vedo anche le segrete quindi ottimo le
carte fanno cagare anno stessa lei
potrebbe servirmi all'inizio visto che
lo prendo non è dei migliori e fulvio
trovato che cacchio eccolo qua allo
specchio
voglio provare a rientrare ma per vedere
che cos'è lega voglio vedere che cacchio
il suo specchio finalmente la
possibilità di provarlo e sai che ti
dico lo provo batman cuore specchio
muoio
e poi sono così non devo prendere
assolutamente danno è perché sono muoio
posso entrare nello specchio
teoricamente vediamo cos'è starò però è
webber sono sempre
ho capito ma se pio danno che succede
seguito dal non sono morto è
praticamente cosa succede ai doppi re
world basta un danno raga sono morto
perché sono the lost è orribile sta cosa
a meno che non ri uso questo anche anche
la 3sun no per ragazzi pazzesco però
mezzo di coltello che cacchio è otranto
il pezzo di cote a meno che io non
ricordo ri colpisca il questo perché
tutto specchiato bellissima star ora tuo
club si raddoppia le bombe se lo riuso
anno posso di usarlo ok ma io voglio ci
voglio tornare puoi uscire
voglio uscire voglio andare via non
vogliono essere dell'host basta mi è
bastato questo torna indietro
ah ok sono tornato a primi per tornare
normale devi uscire dallo specchio no
vabbè ragazzi bellissimo molto nato
pezzo di coltello
anche perché serve e ti pula e tipo la
chiave ripeta no ragazzi e tipo la
chiave di mega satana vuol dire che il
pezzo del coltello
serve per sbloccare la room bosco sicuro
chi pone cassata nega di avere i due
pezzi di chiave no quindi ragazzi devo
trovare un altro specchio
sostanzialmente trova l'altro specchio
per vedere all altro pezzo del coltello
e chissà dove vi porta perché hai fatto
che ci sarà moto da battere
sarebbe bellissimo è un asse incredibile
perché se si colpiscono nello specchio
con 6 morti nico l'aran hai perso quindi
non puoi neanche essere colpito per
sbaglio la roba assurda
c'è veramente un'ansia pazzesca però si
può fare cioè ci stava riuscendo a letto
perché no poi ha preso d'angolo non ha
capito come cos'è sta roba e la colla
vinilica di giovanni muciaccia avrai mai
boys molto bene perché culo raga che
culo le flop
niente male ai ragazzi del peccato per
le carte che va beh non sono un attività
in proprio potente però già mi hanno
dato due poi argentati neanche malissimo
sparato storto
voglio vedere se riesco a trovare un
altro specchio però non so se si trova
qua sai
secondo me dovevo andare al piano di
sotto perché al piano di sotto
ero ancora nelle fogne e forse lì si
trova lo specchio qua secondo me non si
trova più lo specchio perché devo
trovare l'altro pezzo di chiave questa
roba su un pulsante per terra che non so
che la fia
[Musica]
ho schiacciato è successo qualcosa nel
piano ma non so cosa pillola indovinate
se positivo negativa positiva strano non
ho mai fatto niente però prova positiva
o negativa positiva stranissimo ragazzi
oggi succede qualcosa di strano e tutto
positivo
io sono sti molto miglior schiacciati
ovunque che servono
posso entrare in quella porta col
carrello
ma cos'è draga dove siamo finiti dove
cacchio sofia oddio le pochissimo mi ha
passato tutte le star che cacchio è non
so cosa sia me anni ha abbassato tutte
le star praga che sta non so dove siamo
ragazzi mi ha abbassato completamente
lestat finché siamo qui dentro spero
spero non mi rimangono anche fuori tutta
bassa ma cosa cazzo sono e 2 vado e
tutto moto non c'e nessuno il pezzo del
coltello
oh santo gesù ragazzi aiuto
non sto capendo solo fare proprio il
coltello dopo il coltello chi cazzo è
con te ecco il pilot è in colpibile ho
tolto tutti i fuochi che non so perché
ragazzi chiacchio e questo è un post
bellico sono uscito ma si può uscire una
scusa menti ma continua la vostra
avellino ovunque nostro male che cazzate
ma devo scappare
devo scappare
qui non lo devi ucciderlo scappare da
lui sto male
non ci posso fare niente ma chieco
demonio la uscita ma che male mi ha
fatto male cosa non ho capito dove sto
andando andando avanti non ho capito
sono uscito ragazzi non ho capito niente
di quello che succede non era battibile
dovevo fuggire sono fuggito adesso con
contro un coltello
quindi quando tu prendi per il manico
del coltello poi la lama la prendi nelle
miniere ok e berg 1 a sapersi bene
adesso e ho guadagnato un coltello il
boss quindi non era un boss
c'era un boss non battibile
ma che lo stavo schivando sempre fa
tentando riuscito però non si poteva
uccidere gli umori e quanto lei vostro
coltello ecco a questi sicuramente
niente perché sentono immortali
vicino le monde però il sa quanto lento
o ragazzi sono curiosi a rho e adesso
posso provare a colpirlo pertanto quello
lì forse qualche volta la corazza e non
resto colpire lo aspetta procedete 2 ma
poi ragazzi fortissimo il coltello è
fortissimo
incredibile ho trovato è un dito nel
culo spendere ma è fortissimo il
coltello sto male ho finalmente sono
entrato nello specchio minchia era ora
era ora dopo anni madonna ma che bello
ma tra l'altro ci sono non avevo visto
la gamma ci sono due boss sono un pirla
c'è il secondo post che eric kripke in
bicchia e ce ne sono due
ce ne sono due perché era un piano
extralarge mi sa però porco demonio le
miniere ex tra l'altro anche no dai più
jgp certo gioco pure le mini harris tra
largo nelle coltellate mazzette
meno male col coltello la madonna rega
mi sembra un'esagerazione detto ho
sbloccato a sweet suite è pugliese a
spit conoscevo già vado giù più ad un
menage pitt ha scritto in un momento
giusto
diamo una necropoli da gtech sporco
demoni volevo andare in quelle nuove
liverpool va bene borsellino tattico a
rho è mai mamma e posso usare la ma la
carta di mamma su mamma non posso usare
la carta di mamma sola ma bene
ottimo avevo scoperto adesso ragazzi
comunque vanno in generale è veramente
non so se l'hanno fatta più resistente
ma sto trovando sempre più difficoltà
bastano
ovviamente non si sa mai avevo visto che
pirla
be nice non so se andare su giulio
andrei su però prima a satana assoluto
ai c'è un oggetto nuovo che devo
assolutamente prendere perché il nuovo
anche se non so cosa fa stare in su di
heavy e cioè a quando uccido qualcosa
succede qualcosa
ok non ho capito niente provvediamo non
si sta attivando myst appare comunque
non certo nuovo ecco le coop
se attivato aia porca put ho fatto un
danno a manetta naso perché era un cuore
nero che mi distrugge non è certamente
però mi pare che questo affare di succhi
nemici così che qua a risucchiare amici
di tecnico a qualche danno 9 vede fini
che figo veramente utile è veramente
utile per due cuori li vale tutti sono
maione tutti devo riuscire ad arrivare a
alcuni mamma che ultimamente sembra
diventata impossibile
andiamo al momento di mamma la rega
assolutamente necessario impegnarsi vai
eh no preso da lo devo prenderla ok
aia che pirla e vabbè dai ce l'ho fatta
non ci ho fatto ancora potevo
risparmiarmi tutti sti quelli grigi che
ho perso
insomma che sia più fiducia in me stesso
o la bourse trash
no scusate voi c'è tutto delirio ma a
tutto c'è c'è tutto sbloccato tutto
direi di andare sopra direi di andare
sopra ragazzi perché non so niente cioè
la delirium non mi sento mentre nelle
condizioni di farlo neanche ash che è
quello subito sotto direi di fare isaac
che qua sopra perché non so neanche se i
boss nuovi non so neanche dove perché
sta roba qua a isaac ore il buon vecchio
isaac quegli autori sono a farlo fuori
ragazzi è solo un po scarso
effettivamente è arrivato qua conto che
sta quindi non è che posso pretendere di
fare questa cosa però troviamo effetti
guarda che roba bellissima sta roba
l'hack è male
no a pirla io pirla io va dai ragazzi è
stato figo che i ragazzi probabilmente
sia piaciuto vedere il rapporto mi piace
anche ne faceva notizia
certo che se rischiate hanno come sempre
ci vediamo a un prossimo vito ed aia
[Musica]